I have encouraged a lot of founders
[music] building technical tools, you
know, developer tools to spend a lot of
time posting about their [music] thing
and telling the world about it because
if no one knows that your technology
exists, it's kind of game over. And that
the the best technologies are good at
marketing whether you admit it or not.
Welcome to Dalton Plus Michael. Today
we're going to talk about real startups
versus fake startups. In this video, I'm
going to say nice things and Dalton's
going to make people mad. [laughter]
>> What What is the definition here? What's
the definition of a fake startup?
[laughter]
>> Oh, okay. So, you're setting me up.
>> I mean, I might be setting you up.
>> Let's start with the extremes, right?
Like with the cartoonish extremes. Yes.
>> So, a cartoonishly extreme fake startup.
>> Yes.
>> Is a startup that
>> never builds a product. It never writes
any code. It hires lots of people. The
founders are on the 30 under 30 list
somehow. [laughter]
>> Somehow
>> that was a that was a high priority.
[laughter]
>> Somehow that's the main work product.
The founders have raised money
>> despite never having um shipped a
product or any customers. Basically,
it's almost like performance art. It's
like if you had a modern artist be like
trying to to to disassemble the startup
culture. Yes.
>> In some edgy way. Yes.
>> That's a fake startup. Yes. I like that
performance art. It's like Hamilton on
stage versus actually being there.
>> Yeah. The whole thing is a performance.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> It's not real. So, what's a real start?
>> So, or the cartoonish version.
>> The cartoonish version of a real startup
is where, you know, everyone is working
996. Yeah.
>> And it's only programmers. There's not a
single non-technical person in the
business. Nope.
>> And they're all writing Rust.
>> Yes.
>> And maybe not even R. They're writing
their own programming language
>> to start obviously.
>> To start, of course.
>> Yes. Because it's got a scale.
[laughter]
They can't be bothered to do all sorts
of things. They're just like super
hardcore. They're super focused.
>> Don't have to do any sales.
>> They don't have to do any sales. It's
all self-service.
>> Yes.
>> And I don't know. Like I think back in
our day when we were early founders,
Google was like the textbook example
that I was taught of like what real is
>> just being hardcore.
>> Yeah. Like they look at your SAT scores
and they're trying to recruit you. So
everything about Google my memory as a
founder was we were trained that that
>> that was the golden standard for a real
>> hardcore organization.
>> These are clear caricatures, right?
Right. Like you perfect example,
Google's like one of the best sales
companies in the world. I have an
advertising business, right? Or like
Stripe, which is perceived as this just
like oh self-s serve thing. It's like
one of the best enterprise software
payments companies in the world. I think
this real versus fake startup thing is
interesting because we interact with a
lot of founders who aren't taking a
sober look at whether they're taking a
real shot at the startup game or not.
What do you think causes someone to kind
of kind of slide into the fake side? Cuz
the problem with fake is like if you're
not taking a real shot, this is so hard
if you're taking a real shot on goal. If
you're not even taking a real shot on
goal, you're kind of wasting time.
That's such a great question. Let's try
to make the most um charitable
explanation of someone that's doing what
might seem like a fake startup.
>> I think that humans are social animals.
The way we learn things is we look
around the room and we try to see, you
know, if you if you go to a new culture,
you're like, "Okay, everyone's wearing
this kind of hat. Everyone takes their
shoes off." Okay. You just kind of like
go through the motions. And so I think
some of the most unintentionally funny
uh performative startups
>> might be someone that's just like
they're like a merchant that's just
trying to pretend
>> if you're almost consuming startup
culture solely on Twitter
>> like depending on who you're following
you might just be coercultting this
thing that looks like startups business
>> and you're like wait I thought this was
>> but you don't realize you're doing it
you're just trying to go along with what
everyone else seems like they're doing
and no one's told you otherwise. I see
people slip into fake startups when they
have poor starting conditions but high
urgency.
>> So it's like I've got these poor
starting conditions and maybe I'm in the
wrong place. Maybe I can't work
full-time. Maybe I don't know a
technical co-ound like all these kind of
like kind of non ideal starting
conditions like you know Dalton that
soil is full of rocks and it's nothing
growing it and instead of asking
themselves the question how do I
fertilize that soil? How do I improve my
starting conditions? They kind of tell
themselves grit alone can can overcome
any starting condition. So yeah, I don't
have tech co-founders. Let me just pay
for a contractor to build one. Or yeah,
I don't know what I'm doing yet, but let
me put together a pitch deck and try to
like it's just kind of like grit will
see me through. And grit's important,
but oftentimes I'm telling founders like
use the grit to improve your starting
conditions. It's a lot more efficient
use of grit. You know, it's like
>> do high leverage work. Improving your
sharp condition starting conditions is
often high leverage work. You know,
that's why we tell people to come to the
Bay Area.
>> Yes.
>> Like all things being equal, your
starting conditions are better here. I
feel for the people who slip into fake
because sometimes I think they're
slipping into fake because they don't
have any interest in winning, right?
They just want to be part of the game
and look cool. But more often, I think
they slip into fake because they feel as
though they have to start right now.
>> Yeah. Again, you you said the term cargo
colting. Yeah. You know, to recap, if
you want to out there want to look up
what a cargo hold it is, it's where
>> you would like performatively do
something and expect it
>> to have like a magical outcome. I don't
know. You read the history of that on
your own time, but it's pretty
fascinating. Yes. And so
>> it'd be like, okay, let's rent an
office.
>> Yes.
>> Let's hire people and put them in the
office.
>> Yes.
>> And let's
>> do investor meetings.
>> Yes.
>> That's what a startup is, right? If we
put those three things together, Google
pops out, right? Yeah. Like it's it's
sort of like superficially
>> building infrastructure without with
missing the point that the reason Google
worked wasn't that they had pastel
colored balls, [laughter]
>> served lunch, served lunch. Those
important parts. It was that they built
a really good search engine was actually
the high order bit.
>> Yeah. Yes. What I have found at YC is
like, you know, we tend to pick real
startups, right?
>> We do our best.
>> We do our best. We tend to pick startups
that are probably more on the I want to
put my head down and build developer
tools than on the I want to raise
infinite money and what is software
again. As a result, our advice
is probably more let's call it sales and
revenue oriented than people would
expect. How do you think about that?
Like who who are we actually talking to
when we're giving that advice?
>> Advice is most helpful when it's
something that you never would have done
on your own. Yeah.
>> Like if we're just telling you to do
stuff you would already done.
>> Yeah.
>> That's not useful. Like what was that?
Did you see the the tweet recently where
it was like Ben Horwitz was like, "Oh,
some VC told me to only hire a players."
And I'm like, "Thanks, dumbass. That
never would have occurred to me. Only
hire a players. That's amazing advice. I
was going to hire." [laughter]
>> So So basically, if you're just telling
people they're already going to do.
>> Yeah.
>> That's not that useful.
>> Yes. But telling people things that they
never would have cooked up on their own.
Yes. Or that they sort of need
inspiration or a pep talk to do is
actually pretty important. Yes.
>> And so when we take some super technical
teams
>> and we're like no, you should you should
hire sales people.
>> Yeah.
>> Or you should sell yourself.
>> Not try to talk customers and sell.
>> That's transformative. And so you'll
notice at the beginning of this talk, we
were talking about the extremes. I have
encouraged a lot of founders building
technical tools, you know, developer
tools to spend a lot of time posting
about their thing and telling the world
about it because if no one knows that
your technology exists,
>> it's kind of game over. And that the the
best technologies
>> are good at marketing whether you admit
it or not. And that Stripe is great at
marketing whether you're aware of it or
not. Google is great in marketing and
you know some of my newer startups like
like Post Hog they do a lot of developer
marketing and that's why people have
heard of it. They couldn't just like
wait in the ivory tower for people to
hear about Post Hog. They have to market
the heck out of that thing. I think that
there are myths created about startups
that people kind of model themselves
after like oh like you know Google
didn't do any marketing this guy didn't
do this this guy didn't do that this was
always self-s served forever and kind of
when you take the startup that the
company you think is one and you create
a myth about it that's not true and then
that's where you set your north star you
really screwed yourself right you've
really screwed yourself and I think that
you make a really great point the best
companies our whole job is to get them
to be better at some of the things that
don't come naturally
>> cuz on the stuff that comes naturally,
they're good. You got it. Like just keep
doing what you're doing. Like good work.
>> And if we're in there saying like you
should really build better software,
like
>> we probably made a mistake. All right,
that's real versus fake startups. If you
find yourself in the fake camp, do
something about it. Cheers. All right.
Thanks, Mike.